[Music]
Abby Lee Miller was recently
hospitalized for a lingering back injury
and now et has learned more about the
underlying cause of her pain according
to doctor Michael Russo who performed
the dance Monstars gastric sleeve
surgery last year
Abby's current situation is not a good
one with Abby's consent he told ET quote
her hypothyroidism got so severe she had
an assortment of symptoms bone pain in
her back shoulders arms and legs so what
exactly is hypothyroidism dr. Russo says
it's when your thyroid gland isn't
functioning properly which can lead to
weight gain quote if left untreated it's
been reported people can become comatose
this is a serious medical concern dr.
Russo told ET Abby was instructed by
another doctor to stop taking her
thyroid meds at the end of January
thankfully he and Abby addressed the
issue quickly and he said she's already
feeling better
Abby has since returned to the halfway
house she's living in where she's
serving the remainder of her prison
sentence